we got a topic a little bit we started
talking about people seeing dailies
no no
problem is anybody out there who's
watching this
walk by a mirror what do you do you make
your mirror face
mine's horrible i got slain eyes to
start off with so when i do my mirror
face they basically disappear into the
freckles on my face
but everybody makes a mirror face
because you're making a comparison about
how you see yourself in your mind
to what you really look like i'm always
sadly disappointed but the reality of
the matter is when an
actor is looking at the monitor
they're making a mirror face and they
start going oh i don't know if i look in
that angle
well off and the angle is not for
you to decide that's for me to decide as
a director or producer
if i'm producing this for my director to
choose if i'm directing this for me to
choose
because you don't know where it goes in
the edit your job
is to be doing what you do fantastically
caught up in that emotion if you're
trying to tell someone i love you so
much
and you're looking for your angle you
suck and you're ruining my movie
i need you to be that raw person that is
right for the moment
and if they start looking at the monitor
then they start posing when they do
stuff
and now now you're now you're useless
now you might as well go hitchcock and
shoot their hands from actually the rest
of the scene because you can't use their
face
and their eyes are lying so yeah i do
not allow my cast to look at the monitor
they can look when they've wrapped
on the show if they drop by they can
watch somebody
else's it takes not their own